how's it going bros my name is Bearpaw I
have an update for you for PT pi legend
of the brofist first of all the game is
wrapping up beautifully you bros have
just been amazing with all new your
support and feedback to make this game
really awesome outer Minds is doing an
amazing job I'm gonna play through one
level but there are so many more really
awesome ones and I can't wait to finally
show it to you bros so this is how the
game starts um I will be voice acting in
the game and all the other youtubers and
people are gonna be voice acting as well
PT pay and that beerus is how you make
bread using your butt cheeks sounds like
a normal pretty pi video right there
great and your video to upload hmmm I
wonder how many views my last one god
this is so accurate triple dot what 0
that's weird
oh my and yet all your fans are belong
to us and now it's your turn to be
contained damn damn damn barrels you'll
never capture me contain contain get
rekt [ __ ] the hell is going out I gotta
find my SIA and see if she's safe ok so
this is my house apparently I live in a
mansion look at that Maya painting so
cute
ok there's something going on in our bed
I better dig it out oh look it's Marcia
ha ha
my studio is a party oh god more barrels
[ __ ] you barrels oh god they keep coming
I love how it's so accurate that Marcia
would just be oh my god they keep coming
Jesus Christ there's more people for me
to rescue all right well we got over
here and our sofa that should be Edgar
right
Stefano chiffon a jersey party of course
I think all the Maga all the I look Oh
God
blue barrel what the [ __ ] are you Sonic
barrel now Charlotte Brown I'm so bad at
this game okay wait wait I'm good I
promise follow a mouse yeah so the broad
coins you can use to buy upgrades later
in the game I'll show you some of them
oh god it's outside here's our kitchen
ha ha ha I like how they took like
snippets of my house and put them in
there it's okay yeah I love the
background it's so beautiful
all right what do we got in our shed dr.
crab health upgrades available awesome
okay there's a secret here I don't know
if I should show it there we go
ah damn it oh no barrel baby barrels
they're so cute yeah boy that's how it's
done
where's Maya Edgar oh my god no but not
to burn I got one health oh good the
sofa contains health of course
Edgar joins the party fart Oh Edgar Oh
God
no baby barrels inside them oh man
that's [ __ ] up
stick out the soap but we got Maya yar
yar of course
ha ha ha ok it looks like we got a good
party going what have we got a dad in
the basement oh god they never stop
coming mama barrel [ __ ] you we got the
keys to the car time to leave Oh
someone's calling me
barrel king there's no point in reading
I capture all your friends and Sue the
legendary brofist shall be mine
the legendary breakfast what the hell is
it what you don't know how beautiful but
never mind that my minions will capture
you and the power of the legendary
brofist will be mine
go put you have to shave your face
all right minds yet I'll see you later
Marte is like okay now I can go do some
coke so there you have it that's the
first level of parity Pi legend of the
brofist there's gonna be a lot of
awesome levels I'm not going to show
anything salient development but I
couldn't be more thrilled how amazing
this game is turning out I'm I'm really
really proud of it and all the work that
out of mines is doing is just incredible
for those who don't know the game is
going to be out on iOS and Android
probably by the end of August or
September we want to make sure that the
game is out when we feel it's
hundred-percent ready and not rush for a
date but that's what we're aiming for
so hopefully you bros can play by the
end of the summer and yeah I can't wait
for your us to play it and give me your
opinion on it be sure to keep leaving
feedback to outer minds by a Twitter
I'll link them down below if you have
ideas you can become a duck in the game
that's pretty cool spoilers thank you
both so much for all your support
without you I wouldn't even be able to
work on a cool product like this and
it's just so amazing to bring it to you
this is your game after all bro so
without further ado stay awesome bros
and of course it might say is gonna be
part of it and she's gonna be a
character which I can change you right
now hey how's it going Emma - oh damn
barrels what are you doing here I want
to see if I can actually beat this level
it's so hard
Shannon I saved you damn